[Music]
hey everyone today we're going to
discuss all the things we know so far
about the upcoming live-action
adaptation of the little mermaid if you
liked the video be sure to leave us a
like and subscribe to the channel to not
miss out on any future content regarding
your favorite movies without further ado
let's get started
walt disney pictures will release the
little mermaid in theaters may 2023 it
is a retelling of the 1989 walt disney
studios feature movie with the same
title and is largely based on hans
christian andersen's fairy tale
following the popularity of remakes such
as cinderella and the angelina jolie-led
maleficent it does seem that disney is
ramping up to offer a unique perspective
on the cartoon film series for the
upcoming era of princess enthusiasts
lin-manuel miranda a big admirer of the
original movie will co-produce the movie
with mark platt in 2017 it was revealed
that the walt disney company was
attempting to persuade rob marshall to
produce the film with gene goldman
supplying as a screenwriter marshall was
offered the job as the film's director
later that month in 2019 it was
disclosed that david mcgee who initially
wrote the script for marshall's mary
poppins returns decided to collaborate
with goldman on the screenplay miranda
eventually revealed in 2020 that
practice sessions for the movie had
indeed begun
rob marshall has kept up his busy career
after the best picture-winning victory
of chicago especially under disney's
patronage marshall mainly directed
pirates of the caribbean on stranger
tides into the woods and mary poppins
returns after a relatively short
excursion with memoirs of a geisha and
nine although none of these movies was
as critically lauded as his 2002 film
disney seems to be pleased with his
yield rob marshall was disney's best
pick to direct the little mermaid in
december 2017. this might be his most
tough film so far while marshall's
production may finally be more mishaps
than strikes disney certainly appears
optimistic that with this forthcoming
live remake he will deliver this splashy
new musical to life
the plot is expected to follow the very
same fundamental framework as the
classic with some additional adjustments
for a more modern viewing public as with
disney's countless other live-action
remakes there will be some adjustments
in the new adaptation that we are fully
cognizant of first two new protagonists
will be presented perla and karina we do
not know how they will integrate into
the storyline so far but considering
that their characters were revealed
ahead of schedule their role and
responsibilities are most likely to be
significant scuttle the seagulls sexual
identity has been altered from male to
female supposedly to significantly boost
portrayal since ariel's other pals
sebastian and flounder both are male
halle bailey better remembered as 50 of
the grammy-winning sibling pair chloe
and halle will perform ariel in the
movie adaptation bayley has earlier
appeared on screen but the little
mermaid would therefore be her debut
leading role in a motion picture while
many individuals cheered bayley's
casting when it was declared in 2019 the
actor singer also confronted some racist
criticism
halle bailey was not the obvious first
choice for ariel zendaya was once
considered for the position as well as
some enthusiasts wished for ariana
grande to perform the central character
halle bailey on the contrary was
presented with the opportunity to extend
her legs and perform as the world's most
beloved disney princess in disney's
newest live-action movie adaptation it
must be mentioned that bayley has put in
a lot of exertion as an actress over the
decades she featured in abc's grown-ish
and emerged in chapters of austin and
ally as well as tyler perry's house of
pain bailey also made cameo appearances
in last holiday and let it shine
nevertheless this lead character in this
significant disney blockbuster is
unquestionably her most substantial
project so far
taking on the part of the evil ursula is
far more challenging than playing the
part of ariel the red lippy sea witch is
one of disney's most noteworthy
antagonists she relishes every phrase
that leaves her throat and creates a big
display of every expression audiences
may be more engaged in seeing how this
spunky personality performs although
some fans wished for queen latifah lizzo
or titus burgess to take on the role
melissa mccarthy was eventually cast and
it's effortless to comprehend why the
celebrity was selected her bubbly
personality is an ideal match and she
will create a spectacle for the role
along with halle bailey and melissa
mccarthy and the major characters the
little mermaid cast will also feature
jonah howard king as prince eric our
muscly mortal heir to the throne and
king triton the ruler of atlantica and
ariel's deeply defensive dad furthermore
three significant roles will be played
by david diggs jacob tremblay and
aquafina diggs will play sebastian
ariel's faithful crab tremblay will
perform flounder ariel's tropical fish
buddy and aquafina will perform scuttle
ariel's feathered bodyguard who has been
altered to a diving bird nigerian actor
jude aqua dk will perform grimsby prince
eric's servant who is given the task of
finding the ideal girl for him to tie
the knot carlotta prince eric's
housemate will be performed by noma
dumaswenny who recently completed her
role as hermione in harry potter and the
cursed child lorena andrea and kaja
mohammar portray the brand new
protagonists perla and karina
respectively
alan menken who earlier ended up scoring
and co-writing music for the original
movie stated in 2017 that he would come
back as the film's songwriter and
co-write new tunes with producer
lin-manuel miranda approximately three
months later menken disclosed that his
project in the film's songs had been
halted due to miranda and mark platt's
obligations to mary poppins returns
miranda believed that trying to replace
the classic film songwriter the late
howard ashman would certainly fall well
short of ashman's work making the
argument that no one could compose like
him menken officially confirmed in 2019
that he and miranda composed a brand new
piece of music for prince eric and
disclosed that he and miranda wrote four
or five original tunes for the motion
picture along with a new single for eric
and ariel a new track for king triton
and a piece of music for scuttle hallie
bailey officially confirmed in 2020 that
the classic film song part of your world
will certainly appear in the new
adaptation
on the 26th of may 2023 34 years just
after the theatrical release of disney's
the little mermaid disney animation
studios will once again welcome audience
members to be a component of ariel's
universe with their recently relaunched
live-action film adaptation tentatively
announced for 2021 as well as 2022
official launch numerous disruptions
have pushed the big screen reimagining
into its existing 2023 launch date right
during the summer blockbuster period
whereas the memorial day holiday weekend
has not always been highly fruitful for
new releases it did well for disney's
aladdin disney is holding out hope that
this film adaptation will be equally
fruitful the little mermaid remains in
post-production but you will have your
first glimpse at disney's d23 expo on
september 10th 2022 the wider populist
will probably see a movie poster for the
live action remake whereas those
participating in the disney studios
board will see unique clips from the
motion picture
that's it for today how are your
feelings about the little mermaid movie
we are already very excited about the
first trailer which you'll of course see
here on our channel as soon as it's
released what are your expectations from
the live action remake and halle bailey
playing the famous disney princess ariel
let us know in the comments down below
be sure to leave us a like if you
enjoyed the video and subscribe for more
content on the biggest upcoming
blockbusters in case you can't get
enough from our original content you can
also find previews for several other
upcoming blockbusters on our channel for
the action fans we have transformers
rise of the beasts where optimus prime
now has to deal not only with
decepticons but also a new enemy faction
called maximals in aquaman 2 the lost
kingdom the sequel to the huge box
office hit from 2018 jason momoa will
have to fight an even stronger black
manta to retain his role as the king of
atlantis and in our preview for sonic
the hedgehog 3 we discuss the first
story details and interesting theories
for the third outing of our favorite
blue hedgehog until next time
[Music]
you